what percent of Americans do you think
are transgender
I would say
before it was cool to be transgender or
well before it was probably like I would
say 1.5 and now it's probably like 20
okay this is something we see when um
anti-semitic conspiracy theorists are
asked
how many Jews do you think there are and
very often they'll say you know in the
world they'll say oh it's like five
percent of the population or it's ten
percent twenty percent thirty percent
and then you go actually it's it's 0.2
percent of the global population is
Jewish one of the things that's common
is folks who see groups as problematic
will dramatically overstate their
prevalence in the population the the um
uh islamophobic folks will often say oh
I don't know like 10 of the US must be
Muslim or something like that really
common thing